dink-dink welcome back to the gingely in
podcast welcome back and pop pop this is
brought to you by me undies the softest
underwear and the best underwear that
you can find anywhere ever delivered
right to your door to get 15% off your
first pair plus free shipping and a
hundred percent satisfaction guarantee
go to me undies that's meu n di es comm
/ - no Julian best underwear in the
whole world
don't miss Botz are and supporter of the
podcast hard hardcore supporter of the
podcast so shout out to them always also
guys wink it's a wine delivery and
selection service that helps you pick
out wine that your body doesn't even
know it wants but it does they help you
by getting your flavor palate with a
flavor profile quiz that you fill out
and then they send wine to your door
right now guys discover great wines and
they go to try wink that's t ry winc
comm slash Jenna and Julian get $20 off
your first shipment and they will cover
the shipping or you can hit the link
down below
and lastly guys the wonderful post mates
get food delivered to your door this is
all about delivering to your doorman
stay home yeah
so post plates is the delivery service
for restaurants that might not have
delivery options so if you have a
restaurant that you like to go to
chances are post mates will be able to
pick it up for you and deliver it right
to your house right now use code Jenna
Julian for a hundred dollars of free
delivery credit for your first 7 days of
using post meats just download the app
in ode to the code
thank you sponsors thank you sponsors
one time I post made it a fire pit from
Target so I've reached peach peak post
meats mmmmmm that is peak post mates
yeah ladies that's good well we wanted
to burn stuff in the backyard where we
intoxicated yeah
yeah the burned stuff in the backyard
and I was like oh you guys can't burn
that in the like gas fire pit that we
have lit hold on let me see if target
has one and then I post mated it with it
was worth it sometimes you just kind of
postmates some random [ __ ] post me to
the most obscure items from like grocery
stores before we go do a full shop then
you forget forget one thing so instead
of running all the way back out post
Pete's stuff but that point you already
have something on the stove and it's
cooking and you just can't leave it on
there it'll get ruined mm-hmm I'm making
a roux and I need someone else to go
pick up some capers for me because I
forgot mm-hmm
you know I do I love [ __ ] ladies I need
to I need to say I'm sorry for two
things last podcast I screwed up the
bigger hurt in the big unit I don't know
how I did that oh we forgive you but
also I gravely apologized to all Buffalo
Bills fans I have literally not been
paying the greatest attention to sports
the last few years and I totally [ __ ]
that up so they made the playoffs oh so
my apologies to everyone who had found
that annoying I would have been annoyed
too if I was a built-in so or Randy
Johnson fan those people go sit in those
stadiums in like snow and ice and winter
they love the bills you don't [ __ ] with
Bills fans you know I'm that's why I'm
apologizing yeah Buffalo is the cold
[ __ ] place and they really show out
for them bills
yeah like or mm-hm they paint their
bodies yeah they do paint their bodies
and they go show up shirtless in the
snow mm-hmm they really out here they're
literally out there get to a man that
supports you like a Buffalo Bills there
that's honestly a I like that saying
what are we doing today so I wanted to
like I don't know I feel like it's it's
never a bad time to go a little spooky
and scary you know what I'm saying
this is Halloween is it almost Halloween
Oh have you thought about what you're
gonna be for Halloween this year what
are you gonna be I don't know but
Jason's gonna be Joe's
that's funny I'm still like I keep
blowing it about I keep thinking about
being Trisha Paytas coffee maker I think
maybe I should do it this year
you just cover yourself in like crystals
but pink ones
that's so obscure yeah that's great okay
yeah I mean it's not like we have
anywhere to go
are we gonna go anywhere hours covering
myself in rhinestones and then we would
just sit here and hand out candy to
children do we have a party to be at her
nose no anyways I wanna the last like
handful years I haven't planned any good
costume I mean the last cool one we did
was green beans
um excuse you we were two peas in a pod
we were both peas we weren't two podrían
beans we were not two peas in a pod
we were two p-pods we were two p-pods
separate but together they're two peas
and two pods whatever you know two fast
three pods Wow too fast but one year we
were ninja turtle doves which was really
cool that's when I peaked yeah yeah
that's one of my Halloween game peaked
when you basically from scratch made us
not only Ninja Turtles but ninja turtle
doves yeah it was great we basically
just wore green leotards I made us like
really pretty beautiful turtle shells
with rhinestones and shimmers and all
kinds of stuff and then we wore wings
and engine turtle masks we're ninja
turtle doves
when is Halloween we have two months
yeah this is way too early
whatever I was saying it's never too
like a bad time to get a little scary I
agree with so I was falling down a
little bit of YouTube whole like I
always sue and I was yeah I feel like
I've watched a fair amount of like ghost
hunting shows and like ghost paranormal
theme related shows and I like to share
my own bias I do sort of buy into the
idea of an EVP or an electron is an
electronic voice phenomenon phenomenon
which means you record using an audio
device like a room
house and sometimes people hear voices
and in places where they can't hear them
with the naked ear but when they hear
them back recorded they could hear
something yes I feel like I buy into a
little bit behind the idea of that and
that the the energy of the ghosts or
whatever you can't hear with your ear
but if you were to record it you could
are like if you take a picture and you
see an orb or like energy because I I
think that goes surreal you know mm-hmm
I totally buy into the idea that dogs
and little kids can see ghosts and greed
energies and stuff like that and I've
had experiences where I've totally have
no reason to not think that it's a thing
you know huh it's not that I'm like
ghosts are real and y'all can [ __ ] off
it's like I have no reason not to
believe people when they say that
they've seen ghosts or had ghost
experiences or stuff like that so I was
listening to some EVP recordings I
thought it'd be fun if we just sat here
and just listen to some EVP recordings I
talked about like what we think so why
is an EVP recording machine different
than just like say an audio recorder I
don't want the answer to that hmm I
don't know how these people do their
jobs well all I know is that we staged
this house up and down before we moved
in just to get rid of any badinage have
you have you ever had any like any
footage or anything like that where you
went back to watch it or listen to it
and it was weird like that
no but you went to that jail when you
went to hey MA I went to a hundred jail
in Charleston hey MA okay you know we
don't mean yeah hey MA no hey ma I was
there for two hours and I was a little
bit intoxicated Amy
no I have no questions how do you have
no questions I went to one of the most
haunted jails in the entire building did
and it answered all my questions when I
watched well no some stuff didn't make
the cut well why don't you just Amy T us
no I just need a no just tell us well no
here's what I'll say
so I've like in pretty much knowing you
and like hearing what you have to say
about ghosts and spirits and different
things like that and watching some stuff
we've watched but mainly just like
talking to you about it and also like
Rome it has a pretty
serious account mm uh we did a podcast
on that yeah you're in a hotel room all
talking about ghost stories we do it
from Toronto right yeah yeah
so between listen II knew a few people I
trusts accounts of their experiences
with ghosts like and just kind of like
thinking for myself like I personally
believe that that is the thing like I
don't think that the sentence ghosts
aren't real is rational I think that
like there are many levels to it and
like a lot of people swear by having
certain experiences with things that
they can't explain so because that they
can't explain it like to some extent
that they're real at least for that
person when I was in the jail by the way
it was South Carolina was the Charleston
I forget the name of it it was a haunted
jail and like thousands and thousands of
people had died there in that jail like
back back what you know in the nineteen
whatever I don't know you can watch the
last minute ribs episode it was episode
six but I forget the exact numbers of
how many people died and you know what
dates it was in operation whatever but
when you were walking through it because
you you walk through it with this group
of people there's a tour guide who by
the way was wonderful
he was he was very like eccentric but
not over-the-top oh yeah it was enough
but not quite too much and just there's
like this heavy feeling when you're in
there like it's kind of hard to describe
but it's not quite physical but it's
just like you sense that it's not a
normal place mm-hmm like it's just heavy
is the best way I could describe it like
you walk into the rooms and they're all
I gutted out an empty and old and
non-operational but there's something
there that you don't really know what it
is
so I never heard a voice I took many
pictures I took many you know instances
of videos and tried to muster up
anything that it would give us because
we were really down for the experience
yeah but I didn't get anything physical
like that or audio I just felt something
and like every room we went in it was
the same feeling and then when you
exited the feeling was gone that's the
best way I could describe it
I don't know just like just like a
something looming that whole episode
though like the way that that jail like
just seeing how human beings were kept
not that it's a lot better today but
like the way that human beings were kept
in that way is like worse it makes me
physically nauseous that's unbelievable
that that's I think that's also part of
like a de feeling I'm describing because
you're there and you know that
everything that they're telling you is
pretty real
yeah and just terrible things yes it's
it's it was a female serial killers yeah
well it she was her boyfriend
yeah and they killed hundreds of people
there do people yeah and she like haunts
the jail and the tour guy was like
sometimes she'll swipe at men who were
on the tour because she doesn't like men
but it's different like if you go to
like a Halloween Horror Nights like
that's all manufactured and yeah it
might be scared you might get jumpscared
you might listen to some scary stories
but just the the the notion that you
know deep down that the [ __ ] that went
down that jail is like
as real as it gets that's part of like
what freaks you out so much yeah because
yeah and I agree and that's why I feel
like dogs and little kids can see ghosts
as they're they're just purely reading
energy but I feel a lot of people would
agree with you and that like I can't
describe a time where I've seen a
full-body apparition and like a you know
some people do and some people have
stories where they've you know seeing
their friends or their parents and you
know they thought it was real and it was
later a ghost or whatever you're all
kinds of stories but I think a lot of
people would agree with you that most of
their experiences are just that
terrifying feeling that somehow you as a
human living can pick up on that you
can't describe and it's you know the
temperature and the heaviness and just
the overall creepiness is enough for a
lot of people to be like that's a real
thing yeah and it's not you tricking
yourself either yeah and there is there
is that aspect to it like the psyching
yourself out or the mental kind of games
you play on yourself when you're in an
environment like that like sure I'm sure
there's a fact it plays a factor
absolutely but yeah like just the
knowledge that you have going into a
place like that that humans like you and
me we're like not only killed but like
died
and rotted away and these were like the
worst people - these weren't like these
weren't like petty crime
you know people these are like the
murderers yeah the killers by the really
bad guys well so and I think EVP and a
lot of ghost recording technology is a
truck is an attempt to try and turn that
horrible feeling that you get in a space
like that into some tangible evidence
something concrete
so we still don't know the significance
of EBP if it's a real thing or not like
it's totally I guess open to
interpretation or up to you but like
yeah it is an attempt to try and find
something tangible to see if that's a
thing but for me like even like Bigfoot
and aliens and ghosts like to me if
something is cross-cultural has been
happening for you know a very long time
around the world it's not just like an
isolated this part of the United States
has people that claim to see ghosts like
it knows no bounds it goes all over the
world and people describe similar things
to me is like I have no reason not to
believe accounts from people everywhere
all over the place even before there was
like you know an internet full of people
that could meet up with each other in
forums you know yeah there's like not
been a part of the human race that is
immune to it yeah which is interesting
the cross-cultural thing is interesting
yeah I mean I was looking at an article
because we were researching for EVP
recordings and I think it's it's a
something that's I guess a good thing to
talk about
I want to yourself which is basically
like why most of the ghost shows and
that those you know ghost hunter shows
are like they're manufactured and like a
lot of this you see you said you had
some tea for us well I mean it's like I
think the argument is pretty well-known
and basic and to anyone who doubts that
ghosts even are real or haven't had an
experience whether first or second hand
that's that's made them believe what are
you doing they're not in my code I need
to do or else we can't listen to EVP I'm
pretty sure the headphones work
Virgo so the the electromagnetic field
sensor on one of the devices they use
basically illuminates a series of lights
that correspond to how much
electromagnetic charge they're detecting
in a room so like we see they write this
is an article in AZ central the problem
is that something as simple as simple as
a cell phone can disrupt the field and
make the EMF sense or light up like a
Christmas tree so things like that and
they point out a lot of different like
holes in their technology and for ghost
hunting or ghost hunting shows not to
mention that they talk about how easy it
is to alter audio hmm like I'm sure all
and they try to make a television show
here exactly and like the the this isn't
like it's fueled by like the potential
of one outcome like the producers the
people on the show and the network they
all want the same outcome they want to
[ __ ] find some ghost right yeah they
know that's good that's gonna make we
have 10 seasons of them finding nothing
unless they really try to be out here
making curse of Oak Island okay and
that's the T and another thing they talk
about is like if you do watch a ghost
hunting show of any sort you'll notice
like and this is what they point out
this is not my words this is their words
but they mentioned that like a lot of
times the hosts will kind of prime you
to experience something right so they're
gonna say like they're gonna tell a
story about what ghosts they expect to
find here or what they've been heard to
say in the past or just stories about it
or maybe like did you hear that he said
X and so then when you listen to you're
like okay I'm listening for now right
that's that's the kind of situation that
they're describing reprogramming your
brain as a crime in you yeah yeah to
hear something yeah
which like that's real to like I know
that like it's almost impossible to be
in a situation and this is this is when
people have ghost stories but other than
those like small isolated instances in
your own life when you're not holding a
camera or an EMF recorder like you're
not gonna
have that truly like just not you know
what I mean like it's it's like like an
uninterrupted like spontaneous
unexpected moment of like hearing
something like when you have that that
to me is like that's the most credible
thing that can happen even if it's just
an account of someone you trust like for
like when Rome told the story about her
ghost I liked rest room and she was like
I swear to god this is this happened and
then she explained it I was like okay
that's insane I believe that so I'm like
well I guess what I'm trying to say is
any sort of environment where you're at
where your intent is to record it it's
never gonna be as good as when you're
not expecting for sure can we listen is
it yeah so we have let's we're still you
know we still haven't fully finished
this set up so I'm gonna play them off
my phone
listen to the most convincing one of the
most convincing EVP recordings ever
captured I tried to listen to this and I
heard nothing
yeah but you you just clicked that link
and then it just plays noise yeah okay
I'm gonna read yeah should we prime the
audience yeah sure telling the story
primal what to expect on the recording
you can hear three females talking you
hear one person say hello baby
then the conversation continues but you
can also hear what sounds like a
struggle or attack then you hear a
distinct male voice the sound of a
cuckoo clock
Oh a cuckoo clock like cuckoo at one
point it sounds like the microphone is
moved then the sound is clear everyone
from Ghost Hunters and the hotel staff
was female on the night of the recording
and is important to know that there was
no clock in the hotel again their word
right mm-hmm
could have been a clock you can hear a
woman tell another person to get off her
then there's a distinct sound of a
struggle and throughout the battle you
can hear the investigators continue
their conversation there's also a male
voice asking for help throughout I
didn't hear
like it does like a minute of this and
then it cuts out and then it comes back
and it didn't know if it was like a new
banger it's like just a link so that
clicking on a on a beat that's the best
the clock that they're describing
because that could if you're using a
strong enough audio piece of equipment
you can be detecting any sort of like
[Music]
sounds like a washer/dryer
I don't hear any talking yeah no I told
you it's gonna yeah cuts out then it
comes back and that's about as far as I
made it but I near any voice
this is riveting right are they serious
I don't hear anything
that was a scary noise but like I said I
should have said please now this is
violent and maybe disturbing so like we
don't know what we're hearing yeah
that's the best comments of it
hold it - oh my I mean it sounds violent
because that's what they said we would
hear exactly that could be a ghost
making lot of crazy Grad cheese sandwich
a literal Aries ghost making a veggie
sandwich failure you know it's [ __ ]
scary no question about that yeah the
sound of it is sounded scary it's not
anything you've heard before
[Applause]
some like a party Oh
that's pretty right that sounds like
feedback no that's only a scream like a
not a human scream it is only that it
didn't have that like I just don't know
how to decipher what I'm listening to
it's just you know it's very scary but
like I don't know what to make of it
I have so many questions what was
production talking at all at any point
whether humans talking is this all fake
in the recorder
like a hurry
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm trying to I'm going to be a door my
thing is like okay this this article
came out this year wouldn't stop it it's
like this article came out this year
yeah listen to it forever be came out
this year and it was it was detailing an
account that happened in January 2007
hmm I have a lot of thoughts about that
I want to cry are you writing an article
about something that happened ten years
ago that's my first question 11 years
ago mister I need a clickbait title for
my job today one of the most convincing
EVP recording servers and like the first
question why you were talking about
recording sold second question detail us
exactly what's going on in that room
yeah because for us I don't know like
were there people talking were there
television show yeah I'll read from it
was from Ghost Hunters meet the central
New York Ghost Hunters based in Syracuse
went to we're invited to it were invited
to investigate an old hotel in upstate
New York beat Central New York Ghost
Hunters is one of the oldest paranormal
investigation groups in the state beat
it's it's definitely scary like
listening that that's absolutely scary
it's like those are not human noises if
I put a tape recorder or whatever they
used to record this in an empty room
listen to it back and heard that I would
[ __ ] myself but like there's no proof we
just have to take their word that they
did that without production doing some
funky [ __ ] right yeah but it's you have
to be skeptical like you have to think
that it was altered or they could have
been at least like the possibilities
there I feel like the visceral reaction
that you get from that though is like
this is scary yeah I sure dared for sure
for sure like the noises that you know
don't come out of humans mhm
those are what freaks you out and I
definitely heard the words hey baby yeah
yeah which means we got a plague Oh
Santa here
ladies look out in men yeah I don't know
I mean I it's listening to that is
straight-up freaky and also sorry I
didn't warn you because it was a warning
that says it gets kind of graphic or
whatever we don't know that it's graphic
that's that's yeah it's true I don't
know it's definitely interesting anyone
listen a few more yeah okay down was it
was a lot it was a lot it was just like
wow these are a bunch of short ones this
is a from refinery29 comments okay all
right I call that collected a bunch of
them this one's called do you want me to
prime them with one so this one is just
there's very short like little sentences
about what they say or what they sound
like just you know this one says I can't
breath around the nine second mark
always a cool ap recorded in empty room
that sounds like a mermaid put a summary
read something like their underwater
sound underwater that that's crazy but
is it just like a person that uploaded
that to YouTube how do you verify how
the [ __ ] River my first captured EVP
with digital EVP or about 19 seconds
into the video a voice says I'm right
here with you
that straight-up sounded like him that
straight-up sounded like he moved the
mic away from his mouth and whispered
I'm right here with you right but what I
find compelling about these though is
that even though like we don't know and
that's what these the ghost hunter shows
set out to do is so like alright we're
recording the whole process you can
believe like if that say that was Rome
or that was me that was there Julian I
sat in my room and recorded this like I
asked the space questions and then I
heard this like you would believe me
right yeah like you would believe that
it's not fake yeah but like I'm trying I
want to believe that these people like
no one altered that Murrell so what the
[ __ ] is the point you know yeah yeah I
don't know if you can but like I want to
believe them hmm which one what he's
like are you here like it wasn't even a
different voice sounded exactly the same
okay sorry I'm just going back to this
one okay this one is called the table
incident I love this video features
several recorded voices the most
convincing one occurs around the 104
mark when her voice seems to say back to
work with me hmm
a table okay hold on I'm going to read
this a table in the bedroom was making
strange sounds it sounded as though
someone were knocking on it and I
decided to set up a tape recorder so
this is just a tape recorder and seeing
it picked up this is not an EVP recorder
again I don't know the technical
difference between the two
[Music]
all right they're giving subtitles they
said Kim come back and the person's name
is Kim this is this is just so like I
want to live with you
I want to live with you hahaha I hear
any of that I'm only hearing it because
I'm literally reading it this is I hate
you
I swear to god I'm hearing it because
I'm reading it I'm not hearing anything
and I'm not reading it this one says
[ __ ] when I hold on
[Laughter]
the next EVP put me off recording things
for a year and a half when I heard it I
jumped a mile took off the headphones
and stopped analyzing the tape this is
known as a class-a EVP and the only type
of ever captured back to work with me is
what they think it says mine you know
was in the room with weak how do I
verify any of that I want to believe it
but how yeah I want to believe that but
I really don't hear that I feel like
it's that that whole everything just
sounds so funky that's bizarre I don't
know about that one an EVP a voice seems
to say get out now at the 14 second mark
what alone no nearby neighbors okay that
one I didn't hear anything
you didn't hear that no what'd they say
Oh get out really yes I mean I don't
know what I heard now at the end I heard
something it sounded creepy
that's not creepy oh I didn't like that
one oh that one got you oh yeah
something gets you like my only thing
like I want to give these all the way
today but last you know like last time
when we went to the no sleep subreddit
we were all taking this story seriously
only to find out that they're all
fiction like I don't want to be getting
that again there was like guys these are
totally fake you know I do like I want
to believe that people have the best of
intentions and are like I'm trying to
capture this for real yeah I like I hate
that people do that and then they like
they create this fake culture like if
everyone was just honest yeah we
wouldn't have to question yeah just use
your own like do I think that sounds
like a voice or not mm-hmm
why are you all God be out here making
clickbait garbage for us to just now we
don't know what's real or not yeah
I'm gonna find another one right now are
you ready for this one mmm
this one's really scary this episode of
the podcast enjoys Tomatoes WINZ and me
undies now a word from our sponsors
thank you for that Wow I was interesting
guys this episode is brought to you by
post beats post mates is the delivery
service for restaurants and businesses
that don't deliver to you you can get
things from the market from restaurants
all over town delivered right to your
door even if it's one small item post
mates has got you covered and right now
we are offering with code Jen and Julian
$100 towards your free delivery credit
in the first 7 days of using post pay
that adds up so that discount code will
absolutely help you also it'll hook you
on to a new app that you will just want
to be using all the time we use it I
don't know if she's coming back we use
it so much even if it's just coffee in
the morning you can't you wake up a
little late you don't have time to make
coffee
just get on post mates get some
Starbucks whatever is around you likely
going to be on post mates and it's quick
there's no hassle all of your post mates
couriers are really great they're nice
and they hand you your food and they say
have a wonderful day and you say thank
you and then you tell them that when
they use post nice to use code down
until you also guys wink is the awesome
service that helps you select wine if
you are someone who maybe doesn't know
what kind of wine they like or isn't
quite the expert on wine wink is there
to help you out okay it spelled winc it
is a great service basically what they
do is they have a team of wine experts
that help you select wine based on your
flavor profile so you take the quick
palette profile quiz which is just a
number of questions about your tastes
for different foods once that you fill
that out they will start sending you on
to your door on a subscription basis or
a one-time thing
there's no membership fees you can skip
any month cancel anytime and shipping is
complimentary and if you don't like a
bottle they send you a little replace it
with the bottle you love no questions
asked
discover great wine today discover great
wine today because they will help you
discover it go to try wink that's t ry
winc comm / Jenna and Julian they get 20
bucks off your first shipment and
they'll cover the shipping like they
said or hit the link below
and lastly guys me andis the softest
underwear in the world three times
softer than cotton
new designs each month a wonderful
longtime loyal supporter of our podcast
and us in general Myint dude me nd
straight up comments on my Instagram
pictures like that they are dope we love
it they are family if you've never tried
me on these me Andes comes out with a
new print every month of underwear
they have micro modal fabric which is
three times softer than cotton and it's
delivered to you so you know if to go
out and shop for underwear it's just bra
right to your door the convenient little
package I love their socks
they have socks janet has a bralette
then they make I love their pants
they're pajama pants they're underwear I
love the designs I feel like I want to
run around in my underwear all day and I
do sometimes just because my undies
gives me the confidence okay they come
with a hundred percent satisfaction
guarantee so if you don't love them just
send them back for a full refund and
right now you get 15% off your first
pair Plus free shipping and I guarantee
that you will like it when you go to me
undies that's meu n di es complex
challenge I mean thank you sponsors now
back to our regularly no scheduled
broadcast what what what did you not
like that EVP no that one got me how did
it no sorry I put on his sweatshirt so I
don't have to look at you wait really
just to put on blinders oh yeah used to
look at me in the monitor
yes you be I think I hear an EVP it
sounds a lot like Julian yeah
Julian is the ghost that holds this
house he's the snapchat filter face of
me this is a 30 seconds into this video
just not okay what
what's that way ever I don't know well
[ __ ] I didn't do anything I was just
trying to play the videos down this
article I was getting my voice recorder
ready to see if I can capture some EVP
30 seconds in listen for mommy taken out
at the moment I'm out of it
my arrows asked me had a voice recorder
work so I asked him to say something
after I press record and I would show
him so I press record and he says I love
I love mom but when I played back there
was another child's voice just before my
son speak oh this is the recording
unedited supposedly my god oh that one
scares me I cut off the section with my
with my son speaking and slowed the
tempo so they're just listening to the
mommy part
pretty sure it says call papi which is
kind of spooky since the reason I got
the recorder out was to see if my dad
would leave a message and both myself
and my sister have lost children and I'm
sure it was one of them on the recording
oh my god let's hope if I call papi he
will leave a message and have and I have
missed him a lot since his death a year
ago oh my god
Jesus [ __ ] that one got me that was
creepy yeah that one's creepy that one
is creepy [ __ ] dude call papi that was
crazy like the cadence of that one got
me cuz the kid is just about to start
speaking and you hear like a whisper
even if that's not what it's saying it's
saying something else like Yuki I feel
you didn't hear a voice and your voice
with words again I feel like if I were
to be a person who says ghosts are fake
they don't exist I would have so much
more to disprove than a person who
believes on the contrary right if you if
it like I personally think that ghosts
exist in spirits speak and all sorts of
different ways and try to communicate
like there have been so many so many
accounts of people hearing this [ __ ] so
if you're someone who doubts that they
exist at all you have a lot to disprove
you have a lot on your plate yeah I just
I I like I believe people when they tell
me that they've had experiences and I
don't need any evidence I just believe
that they felt something or heard
something like that's enough for me to
be like I believe it yeah I think all it
takes is listening to someone you
absolutely trust say I swear up and down
that this happened you know well I think
we have one real ghost real local goes
EVP recordings from the South Coast
audio ok this was recorded in Fall River
Massachusetts at the famous Lizzie
Borden Bed and Breakfasts this is yeah
Beach his voice is something to be
Lizzie Borden saying something all right
six
everything you have to poop on them yeah
right
honestly if I was a ghost and I had the
ability to say [ __ ] first of all I'd be
a Virgo ghost and I'd just like clean up
people's cabinets up and you come around
and like pick up a little bit you know
what I'm saying but I also wouldn't say
things like call poppy or like I would
be like oh yeah do you think do you just
think that ghosts want to be cryptic no
or do you think that that's the only way
they like once there are ghosts they
can't speak fluent English or something
or I don't know any of the thought
processes that go behind the way that
people come up with this stuff like how
they think it works or what what happens
I don't know but I think that it takes a
certain amount of energy right for the
ghosts of manifests into a voice or
whatever so they're like they only have
so much energy to make you know a short
sentence of something it's not like
they're in a corner with endless energy
and can be like that's a good way to
know it's me [ __ ] that's really how
because they're like their ability to
cross through whatever in the form of an
audio yeah is limited so they'll say
like a couple things just like an orb
like the theory behind that is like they
have enough energy to sort of manifest
into like something for like a flash you
know what I mean like a flash of light
or like something that moves a little
bit but they only have so much energy I
feel like that spot on because if they
were able to just be present they
wouldn't be as scary yeah but I would
save up all my energy to be like
and then I Teeter out for like a week
you know what I mean like there's a
there's a [ __ ] ghost in my house that
tries to sing the pennywhistle part to
my heart will go on listen I feel like
ghosts are just like people right
because they're literally people so you
have some mean ghosts some crank you go
some upset ghosts with unfinished
business and then maybe you have some
funny ghosts that just want to like [ __ ]
around you know I think it's fair I
think it's fair I think you would
absolutely be a troll ghost like you
know who's the biggest troll ghost is
like Bloody Mary the person that
allegedly shows up in your mirror like
that's a troll ghost move yeah that is a
troll ghost move she's like I died in a
horrible fashion I look like hell you
know what I'm gonna do show up and
people who [ __ ] Mira [ __ ] yeah that
one scared me when I was a kid
this one was corded in Dartmouth
Massachusetts I believe to be a little
girl saying hello Tara or Tara oh that's
sweet so much going on so much going on
yeah I was like sounds just way jumbled
I don't know that's another one were
it's like okay how many people are
talking yeah the south coast is full of
old mills some of them are still being
used in new ways but some of them are
still empty and possibly haunted the
recording of a scream is believed to be
the voice of someone during a tragic
accident
so you say tragic accident
I say demon [ __ ] that is the [ __ ]
demon that's a demon y'know sounds like
a demon it sounds like what we think a
demon sounds like it sounds like that
first one that we listened to it was
like oh you hear an interaction like nah
[ __ ] I hear like two demons [ __ ]
hanging out like scratching each other's
faces for fun yeah I wonder if there's
ever a situation where someone's
recording EVP like but with a not
without headphones on like so they're
not monitoring it yeah
so that cuz I feel like some of these
people are just talking over the ghost
like stop talking yeah I thought that
was sort of the point it's like like you
hearing some of them they're like if
you're here let me know and then you
leave like you know a bunch of silence
so you can go back to it and listen to
silence or you just leave it in a room
and have it record silence mm-hmm and
then you come back and just listen to it
after the fact you're not like all right
y'all let's throw my birthday party in
here and and record the whole thing in
case we hear any voices another
recording from a private home this one
in a cush net a very haunted old New
England towns believed to be saying
stitch in time saves nine
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hello when did they say that
and also that sounded like it was
completely altered and almost part of a
movie like that had sound effects
it sounded like someone's musical
interpretation of aliens hanging out
aliens being buds much of the south
coast was built on sacred ground John
Collins Cemetery and North Dartmouth is
very spooky and this sound was recorded
late at night there before you come back
here radio is the last one we're
recording from a private home in Fair
Haven Master these are all message she
says Fossum there's been that is being
played backwards the name Bob is
allegedly being said why is it being
played back okay you know
yeah I'm gonna go ahead and not buy into
that one that one's just it's just
jumbled again just like I will started
talking this sound of whispering on tape
really does creep me out like it creeps
me out
yeah mm-hmm I agree I think the one that
got me the most was the one that says
call papi
cuz it happened you can tell like some
of them you hear and it's almost too
perfect they're like are you here and
then in a weird voice and a perfect
cadence after they're like oh right this
one was like the kid was almost talking
over the ghost yeah which made it feel
real because it wasn't like timed up and
clean and perfect but I don't know I
would love to hear if you guys have
accounts of spirits talking or
communicating or making noise or showing
up in pictures
dude the picture one is a creepy one I
know that there's a subreddit out there
where there are like unexplained photos
or whatever that's a creepy I saw Brett
in fact we should do a podcast like that
yeah that would be crazy yeah but yeah
let us know if you have any accounts of
any creepy [ __ ] but this was fun
it's cool to listen to like there's it's
so different like you think they're all
using sort of the same technology to
record silent spaces and yet they all
sound so different yeah which leave so
much room for just like [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know which cuz that's what I was saying
is likely if you're not if you don't
believe in any of this you have a lot to
disprove there's just so much out there
yeah fake or not there's just a ton of
different yeah but I do I feel like it's
a thing but it is hard to listen to some
of those and be like a hundred percent
man like I don't I just don't know yeah
but I do think it's cool I like
listening to it I like this it's like a
nice fun hole to follow that's creepy
okay it is well some of those really did
give me chills yeah for sure
I hope we don't have any ghosts here no
we good
I'm scared well if we do hopefully
they're trolls I'm obeah troll goes
you know like I don't like why do ghosts
just like you hear footsteps if I was a
ghost I would save up all my energy to
make it sound like I was walking down
stairs and the loudest pair of
flip-flops you ever done [ __ ] heard
right
yeah like I said of hearing just like my
foots up see footsteps you're heard like
but like that night Yuri the lap of that
flip-flop or like or like scuffing your
shoes like sliding them under the ground
no my I would manifest in the sound of
bouncing a basketball as loud as I could
in the house I would [ __ ] y'all I would
just be heavy breathing
Julian that is so scary
here if you're like if you're in a new
house and you go check in the cellar to
make sure things are working you hear
that is so [ __ ] scary this is just so
scary Julian well whatever that's
probably just my girls that made it
sound like wax and wax in your leg is
something just like I'm just gonna be a
guy that yells out subscribe Oh Madge n'
so let's theorize for one second then
ghosts are people who have passed and
are somehow in this like universe there
somewhere but they can still sort of
manifest energy and speak to us or
appear whatever this generation of
ghosts turns into people being like you
can wear my sweater so good you imagine
that's probably what's gonna be come
Wow and with that that will conclude our
podcast this week thank you guys for
hanging out we hope you have a wonderful
week a wonderful day and if you have
interactions with spirits I hope it's
positive see you guys next week goodbye
[Music]